all right I've been saying for some time
I think tomorrow's election is the
beginning I don't think it's the end of
a phase I think it's the beginning of a
phase it's going to be the beginning of
a phase in which Republicans take
whatever wins they get tomorrow and
they're going to get some we don't know
how many we don't know what they'll
control but they're going to get some
wins tomorrow and they're going to use
those wins overtly to try to set up a
presidential election in 2024 where they
can't lose and what I mean by that is
even if their opponent gets more votes
they will try to find a way to still get
their candidate in the Oval Office
it is increasingly looking
like Donald Trump may be that candidate
axios has published an exclusive report
that Donald Trump is planning to
announce his candidacy on November 14th
Jonathan Swann reporting former
president Trump's Inner Circle is
discussing announcing the launch of a
2024 presidential campaign on November
14 with the official announcement
possibly followed by a multi-day series
of political events
why it matters Trump and his top
advisors have been signaling for weeks
that a 2024 announcement is imminent but
the discussions reached the point that
allies are blocking off days in their
calendars for the week after the
midterms and preparing to travel
Trump long planned to announce shortly
after the midterms even toyed with
announcing before November 8 to try to
get ahead of Rivals
in recent weeks Trump has been inching
closer and closer to straight up saying
that he is running
now it is possible that he will indeed
announce on November 14th
it's also possible that he will announce
tonight and the reason I say that is he
straight upset it last night at his
rally in Florida let's take a listen to
what he had to say I will probably have
to do it again but stay tuned
so the crowd cheers for a while and then
uh in a moment we'll turn the audio back
up Donald Trump says keep an eye on my
rally in Ohio tomorrow that's tonight
and we're going to be live with that
rally indeed uh take a listen to what
Donald Trump ultimately said about it
[Applause]
that's pretty good thank you
stay tuned to tomorrow night in the
great state of Ohio stay tuned we have a
big we have a big rally there
for JD we have a big big rally yep so it
may be tonight it may be next Monday but
at this point it doesn't seem as if this
is all for nothing it does appear as
though he is setting up a run
and when I say this is the most
important midterm election I've ever
covered
a huge part of the reason is because
it's a setup election oh that that
almost got that almost got dicey it's a
setup election for 2024. and
I believe that the next two years are
going to be completely insane and we're
going to need to really be on our guard
because by sheer stupidity to some
degree they failed to really come close
to stealing it in 2020.
they're going to be way more prepared
this time around
and we need to be ready for that I'll Be
Live on YouTube twitch and Facebook
tonight with the Ohio rally also we've
got an Obama rally and then we will have
live election results tomorrow night
if you have a friend or loved one who is
passionate about the environment here is
a perfect holiday gift our sponsor
established titles is a project that
lets you ceremonially purchase as little
as one square foot of dedicated land in
edelston Scotland so that you can call
yourself a lord or a lady like the
historic Scottish tradition some people
even change their plane tickets or
credit cards to include Lord or lady
your title pack comes with an official
certificate you can see exactly where
your plot of land is located it makes a
perfect last minute gift but most
importantly established titles plants
one free tree for every plot of land
sold established titles does really good
work all over the world with
reforestation organizations like one
tree planted and trees for the future so
you'll have a great laugh whether you're
Scottish or not I'm not but you're
giving the give gift of reforestation to
fight climate change if you use my link
you'll get 10 percent off and your plot
of land will be right next to mine you
can see it on a map go to established
titles.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman for an extra 10 off on top of
their Black Friday deal the link is down
below